Trisha, what's up? Trisha, what's going
on with you?
Hey, I don't know the topic. I've never
done a live video before.
And I have my sons here. Well, I have
twin boys.
Look. I'm nervous.
Um Let me know if you
>> their dad
I don't know. I've always watched you
and got logic, so You got logic. So,
what about you doing that? So,
[clears throat] their dad was Muslim and
I'm a Christian, but I wasn't strong in
my faith and I agreed to let their dad
you know, show them Islam. They have
Arabic names.
And I wasn't strong in my faith.
I didn't really know at the time we
needed
>> Do you want to be seen on camera or not?
Uh you want me to be on camera?
>> Be on camera.
>> Let's have you on the camera Yeah, I'm
okay. Turn off. Yeah, we're fine on
camera. Okay.
>> Uh one is coming home from work, so I
don't know if he wants to get on.
I'm in here.
>> have one of
So, what nationality is the dad?
Huh? What nationality is the dad cuz you
said you married a Muslim.
He's African-American.
Oh, so he's a convert.
>> Louisiana.
Did he convert to Islam?
Their dad
>> Louisiana, but the twins yeah. You don't
know that their dad
>> to Islam?
Uh I don't know. He said he got involved
in Islam when he was younger. I think on
to
Yeah, he converted. Okay, so I'm here.
What how can I help your boys? How old
are they? Uh I just feel like it's my
fault because I wasn't strong in my
faith.
And uh
hold on one second. I was getting a
call.
Because I wasn't strong in my your
biceps, dude. Shoot.
What's up with that biceps, holmes? You
look like Bruce Lee. Shoot. Ripped. Come
on now.
Yeah, I love you, bro.
>> Hey, man. I watch you all the time, too.
Frost I watch you all the time, too.
Hey, man. I'm about to get us some on
the computer. I should have did it on
the computer, uh
Sam. Can you guys hear me?
All right. Where are you at? Do you want
to go on the computer and come back on?
Come back on. Go on the computer.
Yeah, I'm going to go on the computer.
My daughter's on the computer, brother.
>> with my son. You You can start with my
son. Where are we all now? Are we on a
computer or we on a It's going to take a
time. We're on the phone, but it's all
good. I hear you.
Okay, yeah.
So, what's your name? She said you got
an Arabic name.
My name is Khalid Cersei, but Khalid?
Khalid, like Khalid ibn Walid.
Khalid, yeah.
They call me Khalid in America and in
the Middle East they could call me
Khalid, yes. Yeah, it was Khalid Khalid
ibn Walid, the sword of Islam, Saif
ul-Islam. All right. But yeah, so how
how old are you now?
I'm 23. I turned 23 April. So, she let
you just uh
follow Islam and study Islam, huh? I
mean, that's so
That's been your religion.
>> when I came up, I grew I grew up
Christian.
Mhm.
I grew up Christian. I went I sung in a
choir.
Uh my dad prayed in my My dad prayed in
my face and I I would never understand.
Okay.
>> Uh
the music, the language he'd be
speaking.
It all intrigued [clears throat] me.
Right. So, over time
I'd pick up a Quran, just read a couple.
He had one in Arabic and one in English.
So,
uh
I did a lot of research first.
What uh caught my eye was Deuteronomy
33:2.
Since I know you love scripture.
Huh? You don't want to go there and
think that's Muhammad, right? You know
that, right? You don't want to go there.
You know that's Muhammad though, right?
Do you want me to prove to you from
Deuteronomy 33 that Muhammad What an
Antichrist?
Is an antichrist? Yeah, because you
quoted Deuteronomy 33, right?
Go ahead. Okay. So, you just Now,
remember,
you don't then say it's corrupt because
that means you lose the debate.
Because you quoted [clears throat]
Deuteronomy 33, right?
I'm not I'm going to ask you I was going
to ask you is the Bible correct because
that's exactly what I was going to ask
you, matter of fact. Cuz if that is
wrong if it's wrong if Deuteronomy is
wrong,
then I need you to explain to me which
prophet came and uh
Boss, I'm not going
>> Sinai, Palestine, and Saudi Arabia.
But I know they weren't the names. and
shout and talk over me, that means
you're not having a conversation.
Be patient.
State your objections. First of all,
where does it tell you a prophet is
coming?
Don't change the subject. Answer my
question directly. Where does it say a
prophet is coming? Does it not say the a
book is given? No. Read it here.
Deuteronomy 33:2.
So, answer my question if you want to
have a conversation or debating, don't
waste my time cuz I want to help you,
but if you're talking No, then it's not
going to work.
So, when I ask you again, you said a
prophet.
Read the verse again.
>> from Sinai and he dawned on them from
Seir. He shone forth from Mount Paran.
Yep. And he came forth and he came from
the midst of 10,000 holy ones.
Who is your prophet?
Is there a delay? Okay.
At his right hand there was a flashing
Where does it say
>> Where does it say a prophet?
Time out.
I don't know what time out is.
>> Where does it say prophet came? You said
a prophet from Paran.
Yahweh came from Sinai and he dawned on
them from Seir.
>> So, your prophet is Yahweh God?
Is your prophet Yahweh God? So, that is
answering. the question.
>> My prophet is not God. What does it say?
A prophet came or Yahweh is coming?
It say Yahweh came. So can you show me
where it says three prophets are coming,
one from Sinai, one from Seir, one from
Paran?
What do you see?
>> came from Sinai.
So that there's no prophet, right? So we
cannot move on to show you why it can't
be Muhammad. So now number one, you
misread it, right? That's fine.
Yahweh came.
Okay.
>> Okay, so I got a question here. I got a
question about that.
>> No, don't ask me a question. Hold on.
Don't jump.
>> For sure. For sure. Okay.
So you agree the prophet like Moses, cuz
you quoted Deuteronomy. I'll come. I
promise to answer you, but be patient.
If you want to have a conversation, we
can. If you made up your mind, then stay
Muslim. I can't make you something
you're not.
You agree [clears throat]
the prophet like Moses
cannot
contradict what Moses teaches, correct?
Yes.
Okay. Can you read Deuteronomy 24:1-4
for me?
If a man takes a wife and marries her,
and it happens that she finds no favor
in his eyes because he has found some
indecency in her, and he writes her a
certificate of divorce and puts it in
her hand and sends her out from his
house, and she goes out of his house and
goes and become another man's wife, and
if
the latter husband turns against her and
writes her a certificate of divorce and
puts it in her hand and sends her out of
his house,
or if the latter husband dies
who took her to be his wife, then her
former husband who sent her away is not
allowed to take her again to be his
wife,
since she has been
defiled, for that is an abomination
before Yahweh, and you shall not bring
sin on the land which Yahweh your God
gives you as an inheritance. So if you
understood what he's saying, if I
divorce my wife, she marries, I can't
take her back, right? Cuz if I take her
back, what does he always say that is?
Not allowed
my ex-wife
who got married.
Cuz she's been defiled.
It's an abomination, disgusting before
God, right?
Okay.
I mean, you see that, right? I don't
want you to say okay and then say no, it
doesn't say that.
>> Yeah, yeah, I see I see I see what you
mean. I see. Okay, now you also said
that the prophet like Moses
will not contradict Moses. You just
proved Muhammad can't be that prophet
cuz your Quran contradicts what we just
read. Here it is.
Chapter 2, Surah Al-Baqarah,
Ayah 230.
When it comes to you, a Muslim,
divorcing your wife irrevocably, it says
you can't take her back until she
marries and has been divorced.
So, what the God of Moses says is
disgusting, your God Allah says it's
halal.
Read it for me.
So, how can your prophet be the prophet
like Moses?
You just said it. Don't go back on your
word.
The prophet like Moses cannot contradict
Moses.
And your prophet did contradict Moses.
That's just one example. I can't
>> When did Muhammad When When did Muhammad
get divorced?
It's my first time hearing that.
>> getting divorced. We're talking about
the law of divorce and remarriage. Don't
change the subject, young man.
Your God says if you divorce your wife
irrevocably,
you can't take her back unless she's
married and she's divorced.
God says you do that, it's disgusting.
So, don't change the subject, stay on
subject.
So,
your God says you can only take her back
if she's married and divorced. The God
of Moses says, "You do that, you're
disgusting."
So, you just proved Muhammad can't be
the prophet like Moses, but I got more.
Just with patience, cuz I'm going to use
your own verses.
You think you've studied, you haven't.
You've only been parroting what they've
told you, whether your dad or whatever
Muslim apologist. That's okay.
That's fine. We all make those mistakes.
All right.
Let me just show you here.
>> like you know.
Because I've studied this brother since
1999 before you were born. When were you
born?
I understood.
See, I've been around. I know these
arguments. Muhammad in the Bible,
Deuteronomy 33:20,
Genesis
>> [clears throat]
>> chapter 17 verse 20, right? Deuteronomy
18:15-19.
I I can give you the list that you're
going to give me. I know Isaiah 42, John
14. Been there, done that, retired the
t-shirt. I thought you said you've been
watching me.
I definitely have.
>> been watching you, Sam.
>> All right. So, my point is, your
arguments are not new. It's not because
I'm trying to punk you out. I've been
doing this since 1999.
All right, but
>> Oh, cool. I don't take offense. Oh,
cool.
No offense. We talking about things like
this is serious. Beautiful. Exactly. I
don't care about your soul. If you're
listening If there's a debate, we're not
listening. We got to listen. You bring
all the deal with
other example. You said to everyone,
which is true,
prophet like Moses cannot contradict the
theology of Moses. Excellent. Now, here.
I got to
Go ahead. What's your question?
I'm Cuz he said
in the
uh Tanakh, the Torah,
and the New Testament.
Did the New Testament not contradict
some things in the Torah?
Mhm. Nope, not in the essential mhm
details about God and his relationship.
No. We'll get there. I'll get there.
But, I want to first deal with Muhammad
in the Bible. I'll get there.
Okay. Deuteronomy 14:1, what does it
You are the sons of
Hold on, I got to fix my camera. You are
the sons of Yahweh Yahweh your God. You
shall not gash yourselves nor shave your
forehead for the sake of the dead. So,
Yahweh is their spiritual father, right?
Cuz he's not a physical being. He
doesn't have sex. So, he's their
spiritual father, right?
Is this the Bible?
Yeah, Deuteronomy. You quoted
Deuteronomy 33 through something and
Deuteronomy 14. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You see it right there, right?
Mhm.
Okay.
Exodus 4:22-23. When God sends Moses to
Pharaoh, read it for me. What does Moses
supposed to say?
Then you shall say to Pharaoh, thus
sayeth Yahweh, Israel is my son, my
firstborn. So, I say to you, let my son
go that he may serve me. But you have
refused to let him go. Behold, I will
kill your son, your firstborn.
Okay, so is Israel God's firstborn son?
Yes.
Okay.
One more then I want to look at the
Quran.
>> [clears throat]
>> Deuteronomy 32:4-7.
Can you read that for me?
The rock, his work is is perfect for all
his ways are just, a God of faithfulness
and without and just righteous and
upright he is. They have acted corruptly
towards him. They are not his children
because of their defect.
Hold on. Did that mean when they killed
Jesus?
No, this is long before Jesus, 1,500
years before Jesus. He's talking about
during the time of Moses, they acted
corruptly in the wilderness when they
made the golden calf. That's even in the
Quran as well, that story. Right, right,
right, right, right. Right. Yeah,
yeah, I thought you. Okay.
Keep reading.
They are not his children because of
their defect but are of
perverse I would say perverse, right?
And crooked generation.
Do you thus repay Yahweh, oh people who
are wicked, foolish, and without wisdom?
Is not he your father who has bought
you?
He has made you and established you.
Remember the ancient days. Consider the
years from generation to generation. Ask
your father and he will declare to you
your elders
and they will speak to you.
So, Deuteronomy, which is the verse you
quoted, Deuteronomy 33:2,
>> [clears throat]
>> backed up Exodus, God is a father to
Israel. Israel are supposed to be his
sons and daughters acting righteously.
So, he says, "Is he not your father who
bought you?" Rhetorical. He bought you.
He's your father. Is that how you treat
him?
Okay.
But your Quran says there's no one who's
a son of Allah.